There are only four main types of
businesses. So, your business is one of
these four. And understanding what shape
my business was has allowed me to
develop a portfolio of companies that
generate over $250 million a year at
acquisition.com. And so, if you have a
business, you need to know what shape
your business really is to maximize the
opportunity you're in. And if you don't
have a business, you should know what
you're getting into so you can pick the
right one for you. So, let's get started
with the first shape. So, what type of
business is this business? I'd love it
if you actually think about it right
now. Like, if if there's different types
of businesses, what do you think this
one really is? All right, now that
you've thought about it, this is the
shape of an e-commerce business. So, in
the very beginning, you'll typically
have to get some inventory, especially
if you want to have a bigger business.
No gigantic businesses are drop
shipping. So, if you want to have a
bigger business, like a brand, you're
going to have to do some sort of
inventory. You'll have to front a little
bit of cash, right? But as soon as you
start selling because it doesn't require
a lot of operational infrastructure, you
can grow really quickly. But then you'll
hit these breaking points that stop your
growth flat. And so either these will be
um cash constraints in the business as
in like you don't have money to buy more
inventory. It could be um it could be
traffic constraints like all of a sudden
your ads just stop and then the the ads
don't perform past a certain point. It
could be that you've maxed out your
distribution. Let's say if you're a
retail distribution, it's like, okay, we
got 7,000 more 7-Elevens. It's like,
okay. And then we continue to stay at
that level until we get CVS's and then
we stay at that next level. And so each
of these kind of unlocks typically occur
when you have a supply chain unlock or
you have distribution that unlocks. The
distribution can be literally physical
retail distribution or it can be adbased
andor affiliate um based distribution.
All of these different ways are
promoting it so it gets it in more
hands. So this is why the shape of this
business looks this way. And you also
can get stopped by all of a sudden you
run out of stuff, right? Your supply
chain dries up because your manufacturer
can only do a,000 units a day and you
need 10,000 units a day. And so while
you find the next manufacturer, you're
flat again, right? And this is the
nature of the business that you're
really in. And if you're curious, what
you know experience do I have with
e-commerce? Well, I'll give you two. So
first off, Prestige Labs was a physical
products business. We sold through a
brick-and-mortar distribution base. We
also sold through an online store. So,
we had both of those angles. I had
distributors, obviously, our gyms and
then also uh any consumers could buy
directly from the store. So, we had ads
that were running as well. And so, both
those elements were e-commerce. In
addition to that, um the launches that
we had for uh my last book, the world
record-breaking Guinness World
Record-breaking book, um this is
literally e-commerce. is a physical
product that gets bought through a store
and then shipped out. Like very
straightforward. And so the reason that
this video is so important before I dive
into all the other four is that most
people think that there is something
inherently wrong with their business
when it is in reality a feature of this
business, not a bug. And so the more you
can zero in on, okay, if these are the
big hairy problems that exist within the
shape of my business, how do I put
disproportionate effort on solving these
key foundational issues or problems to
this model that will allow me to out
compete all the other people in my space
that don't know this? And I'm telling
you like this is the sauce. And also
sometimes you'll have to switch three
PLs as you scale too. So even if you
have the the inventory, somebody might
not be able to ship out 10,000 orders a
day. Like when we did the book launch
for me, I had to find three PLs who
could ship out millions in 72 hours.
That's absolutely absurd. Which is why
we had to have multiple across different
states in order to make sure that every
single person got their book within
days, not weeks or even months. I talked
a little bit about the cons, but let's
talk about the pros of this. So
e-commerce,
it can scale relatively fast compared to
some of the other business models. And
the reason for that is once you have the
stuff, I mean, it's really just like how
fast can you hand it to somebody in
exchange for money. And if you have, you
know, a Shopify store or a commerce
store, any kind of online store, like
they can just click and buy and then you
have somebody else who's shipping it
straight to them. As long as they can
ship it and they can buy, you can sell a
lot of them. The issues is when you ran
out of stuff, the guys can't produce it.
You can't get raw materials. They can't
ship enough of them. these become the
constraints. But fundamentally, if
you're within operating within all of
those, as in they can ship more than you
have, you've got enough inventory. As
long as people keep buying, the number
just goes straight up. And so, um,
what's interesting about this particular
business is that it also typically isn't
going to be nearly as kind of keyman
risk from the founder. Of course, there
can always be risk for key skills, but
if you have a product that people love
and people keep going to your store and
buying it, it's a very sellable
business. Okay? And so that's the that's
maybe the upside. Let's talk about the
dirty. So what sucks about having
e-commerce? One of the first things that
sucks about this business is that in
general, most people who own e-commerce
stores, they can do significantly more
revenue than some of the other business
models really quickly. It's one of the
fastest ones you can grow revenue on.
And it's also because people are willing
to spend more money for stuff than they
are for the other three categories
because there's inherent value because
everyone knows there's an inherent cost
to creating it and sending it. So people
are just more willing to spend money on
it because that's t it's tangible. Um
and it's the reason if you look at like
gross sales, what are the what are the
some of the top companies in the world?
Walmart, huge amount of sales. Amazon,
huge amount of sales. It's stuff, right?
And people love stuff. And as somebody
who came to selling physical products
much later in my career, I was amazed at
how easy they were to sell compared to
some of these other things. Which then
brings the the next question, which is
like, okay, well, sometimes they're
easier to sell. people are easy to take
their wallet out. Um, but what makes it
harder? So, this is very capital
intensive because people know costs
money.
You also have to have the money to buy
the And so, it is capital
intensive in that this thing might make
profit on paper, but as soon as you make
some profit, what are you going to do
with that money? You got to go buy more
inventory. And so unless you have a flat
e-commerce business, if you want to
grow, the extra growth requires the
profit from the earlier part of your
growth path to fund the next level of
inventory so you can sell through more
in a shorter period of time. And so you
can have you can be very asset rich in
this business. You can have lots of
inventory. You can have maybe a lot of
enterprise value. But it's very common
that entrepreneurs will get I mean I'm
saying unbelievable numbers. They'll go
to hundreds of millions a year and
pretty much only live on their salaries,
which there's nothing wrong with that.
It's just different than some of the
other models that are out there. In
terms of the things that can also be
difficult about this is that you have to
rely very heavily on your partners. And
so, it's very rare for an e-commerce
business to be vertically integrated. It
it sometimes happens, but it's super
super uncommon. Uh that means that are
you the one who's manufacturing the
stuff? Are you the one who's actually
shi, you know, pickp pack shipping of
all the things both locally and
internationally? Are you sourcing raw
materials or do you have a a raw
material mine that you're, you know,
you're collecting milk from cows and
turning that into protein? Probably not.
And so you have core dependencies on
other businesses. And if those
businesses fail, you fail like very
real. And so having many redundancies
within each element of the business.
Okay. How do we get raw materials? How
do what about manufacturing? What about
uh logistics in terms of pickp pack
ship? Um and then on the capital side,
it's like do we have lending partners
because we might run out of of capital
if we're scaling really quickly because
there can literally be nothing wrong
with your business. But think about
this. If you have 10 units of something
and you make $10 of profit on each unit
and you sell all of them in a day and
the next day 10 more people want to buy,
there's nothing you can do. And so that
might mean that you might have 300 units
worth of demand and you only have 10
units worth of profit. What do you have
to do next month? You can only buy 10
more, right? And so your growth rate
will be dictated by the amount of free
cash flow that the business kicks off.
And then that will be the growth rate
that you'll be able to sustain or only
growth rate that you'll be able to have
in the business. And you'll be you'll be
constrained by that capital. There are
lending partners because this is a
clearly a capital constrained business
if you're growing quickly. Um, but those
are some of the some of the negatives or
some of the downsides. Now, if you own
one of these businesses, what's the big
hairy problem? What's the big problem
that you have to solve? Number one is
managing cash flow. So, you have to be
able to forecast cash flow. You have to
look at inventory cycles. How long is
it, you know, if it's a 12-week lead
time for you to buy stuff? You have to
predict how much you're going to be
selling in 12 weeks. That can be
difficult, especially if it's your first
time. Um, number one. Number two, your
distribution. You're going to live and
die by your distribution. So, ad
accounts, um, brickandmortar
distribution partners that you can have,
affiliates or influencers who have kind
of I would call it synthetic
distribution through their audiences.
All three of those are your they're
partners of yours, right? Product like
great product will always find great
distribution. Great distribution will
always find great product, right? But
the problem the big problem that you'll
have to manage is going to be supply
chain. How can you have enough stuff to
sell, right? Logistics isn't that hard
because there's a lot of there's some
decent um, you know, pickpack ship that
are out there. Everybody always has
complaints because it's not their
business. They would do it differently,
blah blah blah blah blah. You wish they
they they didn't charge you as much,
etc., etc. But like by and large that I
would say that problem has been has been
solved relatively well. Um the next
issue um is going to be
making sure that the product you have
has a brand behind it. And this is the
real nasty one because if you just have
a pure I call them smash and grab
businesses, which is just you're a media
arbitrage business. You know, you can
buy eyeballs at $10 and you can sell
them something where you make $11 in in
gross profit. That's just a smash and
grab business. And if somebody else sees
you smashing and grabbing, guess what
they do? The downside of physical
products is that because anybody can own
it, anybody can also sell it. And so if
you've got a widget, somebody else can
go to China and make the same widget as
you. And that's where patents come
important. That's where if you actually
do own your manufacturing, have some
special sauce in terms of how you make
your stuff, these become the competitive
moes for the business. But the largest
of all of them by far is brand, right?
Why? Like Nike shirts are inherently the
same shirts that other shirts, you know,
shirt companies make. They literally buy
the same raw materials. But why are you
willing to pay so much more for a Nike
shirt versus, you know, an unnamed
shirt? Because of the brand. And so even
if someone can copy every single thing
down to the thread count of your
business, they still can't copy the
brand. And so some of the best uh brands
are in e-commerce because you have to be
in order to get big. And so we think if
we translate what brand does and this
applies to all of them, it's it's super
important with e-commerce because it's
so easy to commoditize um is that the
value that brand delivers is that you
have higher click-through rates as in
more people show interest because they
have a history of good experiences with
you or good word of mouth. Number two is
that you'll have higher repurchase
rates. People will buy once and they'll
continue to buy again. And number three,
you'll able you'll be able to charge
higher premiums for the same thing. So
that means lower cost of acquisition,
higher LTV because they're buying more,
and higher gross profits because they're
buying at premium prices. Those are very
real benefits of building the big brand.
And so when you have these types of
businesses and they are kicking off
cash, that means that that is somewhere
you have to continually invest to expand
and reinforce the associations that you
want your products to stand for, which
also means what affiliates or
influencers you're not going to
associate with, even if they can drive
quick sales. what discounts you're going
to choose to make or not choose to do
because of what kind of brand you want
to um uh demonstrate for your target
audience. There's some brands that never
do discounts and there's some that live
and die on discounts. And so it really
depends on what kind of brand you're
trying to build. But you got to be
specific about it and you want to be as
deliberative about as you can day one.
And so if this is you, I think probably
the most important question is how do
you win? Right? The per I I'll just do
this by describing the perfect
e-commerce company and then you can
reverse engineer what you were missing.
So the perfect e-commerce company would
have its own manufacturing that it
makes. It would have a very trusted
third party or be able to ship directly
out of their manufacturing facility to
you know all the markets that they have.
Now if they're international more likely
they'll have to have international
partners that do the logistics. Um but
even more likely if that becomes bigger
markets, they'll start creating
decentralized manufacturing uh in each
of those markets. So they have lower
shipping costs and faster uh turnaround
times and faster cycles for um returning
inventory. So that's we're going back to
front. They make the stuff right. They
have some trade secrets or unique
partners that they get their ingredients
from or and or they have unique way of
combining unique ingredients which makes
them incredibly difficult to copy. They
have uh great logistics in terms of
pickpack ship. On top of that, they have
uh a very lean team on the paid ad side
that uh is a performance marketing team
that is done in tandem with a team that
understands brand first approach. And so
what does that mean? The most successful
companies that persist over a long
period of time in e-commerce tend to
have a 7030 split in terms of how they
spend their money. 70 going towards top
offunnel and brand awareness and
associations and only 30% going to
direct to purchase. And most companies
that are starting out and the vast
majority of the ones that I talk to,
it's basically 100% just straight to
purchase. You are building a drop ship
company that has no competitive mode and
you will always complain about the dupes
and the the Chinese companies that are
going to come in and undercut you
because they they're in China and they
have some of these other other
competitive edges that you don't have,
right? And so you have to know the game
you're playing because if you know the
game you're playing, you'll know how to
win.
And the last piece of this kind of
competitive advantage that I would have
in this perfect e-commerce business,
assuming they have invested that extra
money to have these premium brand
associations, they have strong
performance marketing. Um, we then have
two more components to it. One is we
want strong brickandmortar retail
partnerships so that you have 50,000
retail stores that are pushing your
stuff out or you choose to long-term
create your own pop-up stores that
actually are your own. There is what's
interesting is that nowadays the model
has reversed. It used to be build a you
know huge brickandmortar presence across
many many states and then start an
online store. The last kind of version
of that was like Lululemon that I would
say that was more popular and that I can
think of at least and more recently it's
kind of the reverse of that. You look at
like the the Gym Sharks, right? they
they're almost all e-commerce and then
they choose to open up these flagship
stores in key locations that are brand
additive. Now on a on a long enough time
horizon once brand awareness has been
completely saturated for an e-commerce
brand then you actually open up stores
all over the place because you remove
the cost of shipping um each of those
markets because people actually go
straight to the store and it increases
their average order when they're in
person. And so the actual cost of
acquiring the customer becomes rent
divided by sales per month.
Kind of cool. And so uh that's what
happens at the ultimate scale level that
many brands don't get to and some of
them just choose not to do that uh
because they don't want to because it's
super capital intensive, right? But at
some point when everybody already knows
who you are, you just want to make it
even easier for them to buy. And so that
is the ultimate version of an e-commerce
brand. Um and how you do it, right? And
it takes years to build that level of
brand, but you can scale revenue
incredibly quickly. And I'll add one
last caveat, which is that you have to
be an absolute savage uh email marketer.
And so the amount of backend the iceberg
underneath of here that exists in terms
of messaging, different process flows,
the campaigns that you're running,
attribution so that you can see your
true metrics. Like these are some of the
like I think some of the best marketers
in the world are here. And it's because
to be fair, once you have a killer
product, it's, you know, backend dweebs
that we're going to, you know, they're
going to be working on making sure that
we have enough product. You can you can
hire the people who can make sure the
cash flow is there, all that kind of
stuff. But like the best I think some of
the best marketers in the world are
e-commerce marketers. Oh, last thing.
The product's got to be exceptional
because no matter what you do, you can
have all the best marketing in the
entire world. If you get someone to buy
it and then it sucks, doesn't matter.
And as you scale these businesses, the
cost of acquiring customers continues to
rise. And so the only thing that you
have that's a compounding vehicle that
can scale proportionally to increasing
cost of acquisition is a referral word
of mouth chain that does two things. One
is repeat visitors. Like how many what
percentage of your sales are customers
that are coming back because they really
like the product? And then number two,
what percentage of those customers are
bringing more customers? And if you're
like, well, what percentage is right? It
depends on the growth rate of the
business. So if you're growing by a
th000% you're always going to have, you
know, more new customers in the
beginning. What matters more in terms of
you want to make this thing sellable is
you want to be able to demonstrate that
you look at this new cohort, how many of
them are going to come by again. If you
can get 60% 70% uh to buy again after
the first purchase, you likely have a
product that's pretty strong. Real
quick, I have a gift for you. This is
the $100 million scaling roadmap. It's
something that my team and I put 200
plus hours into building and breaking
the stages of scaling into 10 steps. All
right? All right. And so what we did is
we broke down everything that got us
basically got us stuck and what we did
to break free at each level of the
business. And if you'd like to know what
product, marketing, sales, customer
service, IT, recruiting, human uh
resources, and finance look like at the
stage that you're currently at, this is
a free gift. So all you have to do is go
to aquis.com/roadmap. You can plug in
your business information. And if you
want our help, you want my help to help
you break through whatever level of
scaling you're at. This is not a
promise. I'm just saying I'd love to
help. Um on the thank you page, you can
book a call. Uh, every month we have a
workshop out here at my headquarters.
You actually talk to my real team that
does does our marketing, does our
emails, does our ads, does our copy,
does our does our does our sales, does
our finance, does our recruiting, the
real people are doing this at a very
high level. And what's really cool about
that is that they can typically find and
spot what the constraints are in a
business like that. And so it's one of
the most valuable things that I could
possibly do. Obviously, you know, space
is limited based on our actual
headquarters. Um, but if that's
interesting, on the thank you page, you
can book a call. No pressure. This is a
gift either way. It's absolutely free.
So that's e-commerce. What's this puppy?
So this is the the the the puppy that
78% of businesses in the United States
are based on, which is big bad service.
So this is a service business. My
credibility with this is that I had uh
six brick-and-mortar gyms uh that I
scaled. Then I had a turnaround business
that we flew around the country and did
turnarounds. I did 30 something
turnarounds over almost two years where
we turned other gyms around which were
service businesses then. So that was my
BTOC service experience. Then I went uh
online and basically built a gym
consulting firm um that sold services
like marketing services, um ad creation
services, things like that to gym owners
across uh the US and basically the
English speaking world. And so I built
both BTOC and B2B businesses um to uh
you know I think mid30 million a year.
And then now at acquisition.com we
advisory practice which is a nine figure
plus business. All right. And so, um,
yeah, so we're very familiar with
building out high quality service
businesses. And so, I feel confident in
saying I can help you grow yours. All
right? And service businesses, um, look
like this because they are slow and
steady. So, if I wanted to make it a
little bit more accurate, I would I
would have drawn it more like a straight
line because this one's taller, but I
only had this much space. All right? But
it's a slow and steady growth curve. So,
why does it look like that? It looks
like this because it's very peopleheavy.
And typically a service business has
people at
all three two out of three or all three
components of the business. So what do I
mean by that? If we break a business
into three chunks attraction, a
conversion point and then delivery,
right? If those are the three comp
components of the business from an
attraction perspective, that's the only
one where you could have a very scalable
front end. You could have just be
running ads. You have content on the
front end. Super scalable. Now typically
if you're selling services, it's going
to have a higher ticket. If it has a
higher ticket, usually a person is
involved. So you might have a person
who's taking phone calls or meeting with
customers at their homes or meeting in
person in order to convert or transact.
All right, close the sale. Once the
customer is, you know, has transacted,
now we have to deliver. And it's a
service business, which means that you
have people who are involved in the
delivery. You do some sort of services
to them. All right. Now what becomes
what becomes challenging about this is
that as you scale it is easier to go
find more product to sell than it is to
find exceptional people. Significantly
harder. And if the thing you sell is
people with a premium, which is what a
service business is, then you have to
find very good people. And very good
people are even harder to find, right?
And they also cost even more money. And
so service businesses in general um you
want to run significantly higher gross
margins than the other three. Uh
they typically don't run high gross
margins and you want to design them in a
way that do run higher gross margins
because you need the padding for the
inevitable volatility that exists within
the business. And the volatility is a
factor of when someone new comes into
any function of the business, whether
you're doing outbound on the front end
or running ads, you're doing sales or
you have delivery. If you have one sales
guy, when you hire the next sales guy,
he's not going to be as good as the
first one because he's got to get
trained up. And so, we have to be able
to swallow slow down. We have to be able
to deal with the padding here. We need
some cushion for the pushing, if you
will, um, on how much gross profit we
can have here because if our conversion
rate drops in half because our new sales
guy's not as good, right? He's got to
get up to speed in 30 days. Then we got
to be able to eat that. Calm down. All
right. Now, the next thing is that on
the delivery side, let's say we've got
one good account rep or two good account
reps and and they've been with you for 5
years. Okay. Well, you finally figured
out a little bit more marketing, a
little more selling, and guess what?
Now, we need another account rep, but
they're not as good. So, now you have to
worry about your reputation because
they're not going to be able to deliver
the same uh same scale. And so, service
businesses are very easy to start
because they cost nothing at the very
beginning. And you literally just sell
your time, which is why it's the most
common business that people do start.
They learn one thing and then they start
doing that work for other people. Very
simple. But then once it once you learn
that thing, the better you get at that
thing, the harder it is to get more
people who are as good as you at that
thing, which makes it like the more you
can charge, the harder it is to get more
people that you can charge that money
for and still deliver that quality. This
is the inherent difficulty with um
service-based businesses. So, I'll give
you I'll give you uh two two polar
examples here. Uh a because I come from
the fitness industry. So, a fitness
coaching business, a gym is a
service-based business, right? Um the
the pros of that particular type of
business is that it's easy to hire that
talent because one, it's low skill, and
two, many people love it. It's almost
like hiring musicians. Plenty of people
would do it for free. They'd coach
classes for free. They're they're
passionate about fitness. um where it's
more difficult in that business is very
hard to number one sell and number two
retain customers because people don't
like working out. Now on the flip side,
I would say many or the vast majority of
businesses are actually not like uh the
fitness coaching business. The vast
majority of service businesses are
people doing work that other people
don't want to do. And so this is the
fitness coaching business is unique in
that it is coaching. The vast majority
of service businesses, there is no
coaching. You just do the work, right?
You fix the roof, you you put in the the
garage, you do the accounting for them,
you do the legal work, you um you build
the website for them, right? So for any
any of those businesses, it's actually
very easy to do the sale because you
say, "I'm going to give you the outcome
and you don't have to do anything."
Right? And so if you're actually good,
almost all service businesses when they
are done for you service businesses
almost never, if they're any good, have
a problem getting customers. the
difficulty they have is hiring good
talent because customers will stick
because you're doing the service and
they don't want to learn it and they
don't want to do it and the difficulty
you have is you got to teach other
people to do it and do it well and so
you will almost always be supply
constrained um in this business model.
So what are the good things about this?
Um service businesses are the least
risky business because you can always
keep a service business profitable. So
what do I mean by that? So outside of
rent, which should be a lower cost
relative to, you know, whatever your
business is almost always for service
with the exception of maybe like a gym
um or like a med spa or something like
that where you have like some capital
intensive stuff, but that's less of a
service business, more head medical. I
won't get into it, but for the vast
majority of the true humans are the are
the are the labor, right? Um if revenue
goes down, you can always cut headcount.
I'm not saying it's pretty, but you can
always stay profitable and you can
always cut it all the way back down to
just you doing work for money, right?
And so you can always make sure as long
as you are priced appropriately that you
can make money in a service business.
Now if you do a decent job uh for people
they will tend to stick around and so it
can be very stable. It's very
predictable. The difficulty is like how
do you triple a service business year
over year over year? Incredibly hard to
do especially as you get bigger and
bigger. Now some of the other benefits
of service businesses is they do have
the potential for high margins. um it's
rarer but the way that you I'll I'll
tell you I'll tell you it in a second
how you can create high margins uh in a
service business but they do have the
potential for high margins but almost
always they have high cash flow because
there's not a tremendous amount of
capital intensive reinvestment that must
occur in a service business we don't
have to buy inventory we don't have
developers we have to buy
I'm getting a little ahead right um but
basically you sold work for 100 grand
your cost on that work was 50 and then
there's 50 grand left over and next
month you're going to sell the same work
for 100 grand and the cost you 50 and
there's going to be another 50 left over
and you can pocket that and so they tend
to be very stable very high cash flow
businesses um and I would say the
majority of them if you do a decent job
have pretty good retention because
people don't want to learn it and they
don't want to do it so what sucks about
this business talent is the bottleneck
right you finding good people is going
to be the difficult part of this
business whether you're trying to find
HVAC uh technicians, plumbers,
electricians, uh, on the home services
side, if you're trying to find maids on
the low skill side, very difficult. So
all the way up it's it's always hard
because even at the lowest skill, if we
use maids as the as the lowest skill
labor for a service business as an
example, well then just finding people
who speak English, show up on time, are
competent, and actually do a good job
cleaning um and want to work for the the
the the amount of pay that uh the price
the pricing uh package that you have
allows for some margin is difficult.
That's the hard part. If you go up a
level in terms of like I would say uh
you know trades then finding the
tradesmen who are who are good and
experienced and can do more complex work
becomes difficult. So it's a more
compliant uh supply constraint business.
If you go white collar then you've got
accountants, lawyers, management
consultants, uh investment bankers,
right? All of these people inquire
require a ton of education, a ton of
learning. And so most of those, like the
ones I just mentioned, management
consulting, uh, investment banking,
legal, like they all have multi-year
learning paths before they're really
even allowed to do work on their own.
And so when you have multi-year kind of
gestation periods for the talent, that
becomes one of the big things that sucks
about the business. And I'll tell you
how to fix that in a second, but that's
one of the big things that sucks. Um,
and often times when you have one of
these businesses, the founder tends to
be, not always, but tends to be one of
the best technicians. And so this is a
double-edged sword because you know how
to do it better than everyone. And as a
result, people tend to always come to
you uh in order to solve the big complex
problems, which makes your life big and
complex all the time, which kind of
sucks. Um and the last piece is that
it's just slower to scale than the other
three models. So what is the big problem
that you have to solve with this
business? If we believe that hiring,
onboarding and training talent um is the
so if we take the position which I do
that supply or the supply of good talent
is the hardest part about this business
then one of the core components of your
business must become your attraction as
in your recruiting process. how you
onboard those people and how you train
them. Because if we think about a
business as the difference between the
the value of the inputs and the value of
the outputs, that delta is where profit
is created. You are creating value in
the economy. And so you take raw
materials, people who are underskilled,
you have a way of bringing them in,
adding value, giving them skills,
teaching them, and then you can sell
that skill set at a higher premium
later. That's the idea. Now where you
have a 2011 version of this is where you
have three or four different people that
all have different skill sets that the
aggregate of three or four of those
skill sets put together uh becomes even
the sum is greater some of the whole is
greater than the parts right you get
even more gross profit and that's where
this gets a little bit more interesting
and so that core has to be one of the
things that you do exceptionally well
and if you're like we don't really do
that very well in our business no
that's why most service businesses don't
scale and the second element that you
really want to focus on is like how How
many ways can you reduce your own
founder technical expertise? The
dependent the business's dependence on
your technical expertise. How can I
productize my own knowledge to such a
degree? And what you have to get very
good at doing is you have to get very
good at teaching. Fundamentally, like if
you're in a service business, you're
actually in a teaching business. You
have to teach your talent how to do what
they do. And I think this is one of the
big mess ups is people expect, oh, I'm
going to train some guy in a weekend to
do something that's taken me 10 years
and then I'm going to get upset that
he's not that good. Ridiculous, right?
We have to have far more robust training
for these people. But as a result, it's
more front-loaded than than most people
expect. But if you do that well, those
people ramp up faster. They stick
longer. You're able to charge longer
premiums, and your reputation continues
to compound over time. So, [snorts]
how do you win with this model? So
number one is that most service
businesses, especially in the beginning,
is they do any kind of work for any kind
of person with a pulse. Very normal. But
as soon as you start to develop a little
bit of business chops, you start to say,
"Okay, some of these clients suck, some
of these clients are great, we do a
better job with this." And so you start
to narrow down who your real customer
should be. This happens usually in the 1
to3 million dollar range is when you
start to have to make those decisions.
In the beginning, you're just trying to
make money. Fine. But when you really
want to scale, um, like you have to
start deciding what business you're
really going to be in. And usually it's
around, like I said, 1 to 3 million.
That's when you decide what business
you're really in. And then that's where
you really start going on this path. But
in order to do that, we have to decide
on what customer we're going to really
serve. And then as a result, because we
have one consistent customer, we should
only have one, two, three max uh
consistent deliverables that we're
giving. So that we can start
systematizing or productizing the way
that we deliver our services. So rather
than everything being bespoke or just
saying whatever you want, your your bra,
you know, your wildest dreams is what I
can deliver. Um you then say you
probably want this problem solved. We
solve it in one of three ways. This is
the way that I think is best for you and
here's how we do And then you can start
driving operational efficiency within
the business which then expands the
gross margins. Okay. Now in order to do
that operationalized bucket of things it
becomes more repeatable for you to then
build training process to each of those
desired steps or outcomes in the
systematized delivery. And so that then
the systemized systematized delivery
then feeds into the operational
infrastructure in terms of onboarding
hiring and training and talent selection
on the way in. All right. And so when we
do these two steps, then the next thing
is that you'll end up having to replace
yourself in um some level of the
operations at some point so that you can
lead the company. So if you were trying
to win here, systematization of of
delivery, selection of the avatar, being
very clear about recruiting, hiring,
onboarding, and training, and having
very good defined career paths for your
talent so they want to stay with you and
not go somewhere else because they're so
hard to get. And so if you're in that
business, typically getting customers is
not that hard. And so then we think,
okay, if then we can just blow the back
end out so we can have 10, 20, 30 new
amazing people who are getting activated
uh per month on my delivery side, I can
finally the goal that you want to have
is that you want to have an amazing
reputation and actually get to the point
in a service model where your demand is
the constraint. Very rare but doable.
Now in this business, where do I
reinvest my capital? Right? So I said
this is very high cash flow. So number
one is that this is a business that you
can live well throughout the entire time
of doing the business, which is why I've
always been a fan fan of service
businesses. The the other business
models that exist here, two of them, um
basically the founder almost never makes
any money until a point of an exit. And
let's be real, exits are far rare that
people try and make them out to. And so
service businesses, you can kind of live
your life and continue to scale your
income as it goes up. Now, where do you
invest your cash? So you want to invest
your cash in two core places. Number one
is going to be talent, meaning you want
better, smarter people who are coming
in. So the raw materials that are coming
in, we want to increase the quality of
those raw materials. Now we still have
the training that we that we have, but
if you're training a genius versus
training a dodo bird, training the
genius is still going to work better. So
we want higher base level people, higher
horsepower, higher intelligence. If we
look at the ultimate versions of some of
the the highest grossing service
businesses out there, what do they all
have? They have unbelievable talent
machines and they attract the best and
brightest, right? So, number one is that
you're going to be reinvesting money
into the recruiting um side of the
business so you can get the best talent.
The other side that you're going to be
putting money into is going to be brand.
Right? Now, brand is going to benefit in
both places. One, it's going to be it's
going to allow you to charge premium
prices over time and it's also going to
allow you to attract premium level
talent because they want the
association. They have their own
personal brand. They want their
association with your brand. Now the way
that I can see um how
scaled up or how progressed an
entrepreneur is in the service business
is actually with one metric which is
what they charge. Now think about how
interesting. So I'll explain why I think
this is a very interesting like
northstar metric. If you do a good job
at what you do
then you should have a supply constraint
in your business because more people
want your services. If more people want
your services and you're supply
constrained what happens? Well, if we're
supply constrained and we have more
demand than we have supply, what should
we do? We should raise our prices. And
as we raise our prices, we should
increase our gross margins. And as long
as we have good training and we can
maintain a reputation, what happens?
More customers come in, more demand, and
then we can continue to raise our
prices. And so, it should be a process
of consistently being able to raise
price over time and go after better and
better avatars, better and better ICPS,
if you want to use that language. Um,
ideal customer profile, I think that
stands for u basically the type of
customer that you're going after, right?
and prospects. You want better and
better people who can write stroke
bigger and bigger checks. And the only
way to do that is to typically have the
track record having done this for years
and continuing to level up. And you can
only do that if you're good because you
have more demand than you have supply.
And that's the game that you ultimately
want to be in. Now, is there a a world
for a lowcost service provider? Yes,
with one very important caveat.
You have to decide day one when you
build this business that you're building
it as the lowcost provider. And that
doesn't mean, oh, people didn't want to
buy this price. I'm going to go cheaper.
It means that day one, every every
decision you've made, you've made with
that north star, which is that we want
to be as operationally efficient as
humanly possible. So, we're going to
offshore all of our talent. We're going
to have as much automation built into
our business as humanly possible. And
our primary USP or selling proposition
is going to be that we are the cheapest.
It is absolutely a game where you can
make a lot of money,
but you have to decide to be in that
game day one. I have spent the vast
majority of my life on the premium side,
which is where I would recommend most of
you go because service businesses are
inherently more difficult to scale
because you have to scale headcount. And
so, if you're going to have 20 people
that work for you, I'd rather be making
a million dollars per person than making
less than that. I'll just say that. I'd
rather make a million dollars per person
because then it'll be worth the headache
that comes with the headcount.
So
that's shape number two. Drum roll,
please. That brings us to shape number
three. So quick guess, what do you think
this is? This is an education,
consulting, info media business. My
credibility around information
businesses is that I happen to own a
software platform that uh allows people
to start information businesses called
school. Uh, and so I have access to
quite literally millions of data points
in terms of what makes this business
work and what doesn't. I've also been
somebody who's consumed a lot from the
alternative education world. Um, and
done a lot of studying on like what
makes these businesses work because as
somebody who is a continuous student of
all games, especially the business game,
I always want to see what makes what
separates the best from the rest. Nice
nice little rhyme. Um, and as somebody
who's an educator in general, uh, from a
YouTube content perspective, like what
are the different models that exist
here? Let's dive in. So, what is the
shape? This shape scales faster than any
other of the four shapes. You can notice
that it's almost a straight line up. And
so, this business makes money quickly
and then it hits a hard stop or becomes
very difficult uh to make it make more
money from there. So, why is it shaped
this way? So, one of the most difficult
parts about um information or education
related businesses is that there's low
retention, right? If you do a good job
educating someone, they graduate. Your
high school isn't like, "Oh my god, I
can't believe we didn't retain that kid
there. The goal is not to retain them,
right? The goal is to actually graduate
them." Now, what's the what's the
continuity program for education? Well,
you go four years of high school, you go
four years of college, then you have a
master's degree, then you have a PhD,
then you have a double PhD. So, they
definitely have an ascension program,
right? But the point ideally is that you
provide more value uh than the cost of
the education and then as a result this
person now has a skill that is more
valuable in the workplace, right? That
you know in in the competitive
environment. That's the point. So the
reason that education can make so much
money so quickly is that if you have a
valuable skill and that that skill is
unique and difficult to acquire in the
marketplace, then you can charge a a big
amount of money for something that
actually cost you very little. cost you
a lot of money and time to acquire the
skill one time for you, but then you get
to duplicate that skill through the
education over and over again through
other people. And so, I'll just use
simple math here. If I can teach someone
a skill that takes them from $40,000 a
year to $100,000 a year, many people
would pay lots of money to add $60,000
of income per year for the rest of their
life. That's an unbelievable valuable
proposition. So would I I mean what
would someone be willing to pay for
that? A lot. The education industry at
large I think the last time I checked is
like 10 trillion globally. It's a very
big industry because if we think about
an economy at large there are only two
things that drive GDP gross to best
product the production of the economy
education
and
education and technology. And that's per
capita right? So if if the per person
what do you got? They can get more
skills and they can have more tools to
use those skills. That's what drives
GDP. And so it's a huge driver of the
economy which is why education is such a
massive market. Now
it's shaped this way for most businesses
though because once someone graduates
they leave which means that you always
have to fill up the business again. And
if you're good at something you usually
get this quick shot up because people
know you're good at it. So you can
quickly charge a lot of money to a
handful of people and actually deliver
that value because people know you're
good at that thing and then very quickly
you make money but then you're like, "Oh
shoot, I graduated all those people."
What do I do? I got to get more
customers, right? And the other side of
this that is kind of bad is that once I
teach someone really well how to do that
thing, what stops them from selling the
exact same thing that I just taught
them? Almost nothing, right? And so
these are some of the this is why the
shape is shaped this way because more
entrance if you teach more people starts
putting this downward pressure. So
you've got downward pressure in that
people are exiting and you've got more
competitors that are always entering the
market because it's very easy to one
create competition. Number two start an
education business because it costs
almost nothing if you have the skill. So
what's good about this because that
sounded a little bit you know negative
in terms of the shape. You're like why
would I want to why would I want to stop
you know here right? Well the great
thing is that there's fast initial cash.
There's very few businesses that can get
you out of, you know, poverty
uh as quick as this. There's there's I
would dare I say there's almost nothing
that's as fast as this. And I'll tell
you one thing that I've learned about
humans over my many years in business is
that people love fast. All right? And
it's also one of the easier ones. So
fast and easy, very compelling value
proposition. Um and I'll give you the
third value proposition. It's also
cheap. So fast, easy, cheap to start.
Wow. very compelling. Now, when you have
something that's fast, easy, and cheap
to start, what what's the downside of
that? Well, lots of competitors, it's
also fast, easy, and cheap for them to
start. All right? And so, what sucks
about this? It's difficult to scale
typically past $1 to $3 million a year.
Now, I think a big part of that, this is
pure rule of thumb, anecdotal
observation for me. It's hard because
most people don't have the promotional
skill to get beyond the first one to
three million. And the more talented the
individual is, the more difficult is it
is for them to scale um the delivery. So
these businesses sometimes start to
bleed into service businesses, right?
They have some sort of DIY, you know,
do-it-yourself self self-led education
thing. And then people are like, well,
I'd like some teacher. I'd like some
help. And so then it starts to get a
little bit of crossover into services.
And it starts to get some of the
negative sides of services, which is,
oh, now I got to train all these people
to be as good as me at delivering this
thing that's taken me 10 years to learn.
And so people take one of two paths.
They'll either say, well, I'm just not
going to do that. I'm going to make it
one to many forever. Which I do
recommend for a lot of people. I think
it's actually not a terrible idea. Um,
the other option they do is they say,
oh, I'm going to get a bunch of coaches
or teachers, right, uh, that I'm going
to teach in a weekend how to do my
thing, and then I'm just going to
outsource all the work to them. But if
the thing that you have is so valuable
that you charge so much money for it, if
you could teach someone in a weekend to
teach it, you're either not selling
something that's that valuable or you're
lying about the fact that they're
actually as good as you. And so the
analogy that I have for this is imagine
I have the world's best uh milk. All
right? The world's freshest milk. And
let's assume that you have no dairy
dairy issues. You're just a good
oldfashioned, you know, Wisconsin boy.
All right? You can just drink your
dairy. Now, let's say that I have 10
customers and I only have one glass of
milk. So, I have two options. Option one
is I can do 10 shot glasses and I can
pour the milk into those shot glasses.
Option two is I can have glasses of the
same size that are all filled with water
and I put a shot glass worth in each of
them. So, I give you this much of a
shittier milk or I give you a much
smaller amount of the same quality.
Which one would you rather have? In my
opinion, most people would rather have a
smaller amount of a good thing than a
larger amount of a bad thing. To me,
this is what the vast majority of
businesses choose to do by saying, "Oh,
I'm going to hire this person. I'm going
to train them for 5 hours and then I'm
going to sell the services at the same
price that I sell for myself for this
person." So, then they get this very
diluted thing. Now, what happens here?
Your reputation starts to take a hit.
And so, you you started getting word of
mouth and that stops happening because
you're not teaching as well, because
they're not teaching as well, because
they're not as good as you. On the other
hand, these businesses where the the
main educator also learns some skills
with promotion. Um those people because
they just continue to dilute down
access, the rate of you diluting down
access is almost always proportional
with how good you are. And so if you
have the best milk in the world, you can
actually give that tiny shot, the
tiniest shot, and it's still good and
better than one guy who's mediocre
giving 100% of his attention. And so one
of the interesting things about this
model um is that with technology
technology has de democratized has made
it even access um for people to get
educated and when you have democratized
access you often will have consolidated
um production meaning if you're the best
in the world you get to do it for
everyone.
So what sucks? Easy to easy to easy to
compete. So it's double-edged sword,
right? Many competitors. You also create
your competition when you educate them.
Retention is almost nothing. And growth
relies on almost constant marketing. And
uh and then you always have a little bit
of reputational risk if you're not good
at ops, which is a totally different
skill set than education. Um where you
can actually scale the other components
of the business. And so reputation can
take a a hit. And that's why many
businesses can shoot up quickly and
either they fizzle out and they become
what I call offer hoppers. So they just
come up with a new thing every year that
they're selling uh from an education
perspective. That is a way to do it. I
don't think it's the way of life that I
would prefer to live but some people do
that. Uh the alternative is that they
just kind of putter along at that same
level and they just get new people in
the old people leave and that's just
what they do and it's very difficult for
them to scale scale. So what's the big
problem that you have to solve if you
have this business?
Number one, and this is the this is the
nasty one, but it's the reality is that
you have to find a way to create
stickiness in a fundamentally unsticky
model. All right? Meaning, how do we
create revenue retention in an education
business? So I'm going to give you a
couple of tactical strategies for this.
So number one is that you want to have
some component of the business that's
consumptionbased. All right? So if we
look at if we were to teach someone a
core skill, right? There's going to be
some components that need to be
refreshed. If I teach you how to run
ads, you're going to need something on a
regular basis. What's that? Creative.
So, maybe I sell you a one-time price
that's significantly more expensive on
how to run ads and then my recurring
price
for the the creative might be lower,
right? Um, a different version of this
is I'll teach you uh this education, but
you probably want a community to be with
other people on. That's what school.com
is about, right? Okay. And I'm a
co-founder of that company, which is a
different one of these models that I'll
get to in a second. Well, it's the only
one that's left, but maybe I maybe I'm
sh I'm sharing too much. Um, so people
want community, but let's be real,
community is less valuable than
education is. And so where people get
into trouble is they say, "Oh, uh, I
will charge $25,000 for this education,
and that might be appropriate." And so
then they make a payment plan where they
say, "You have to pay $2,000 a month or
whatever to to to to pay for this
education." Fine. But the first payment
of that $2,000 so amazingly worth it
because they just got this $25,000
thing. They got this education upfront.
But the day before I know how to do
math, knowing how to do math is
unbelievably valuable. The day after I
know how to do math, the value of a math
course is approximately zero. And so now
I'm paying $2,000 a month for a
community which is not as valuable as
what a community is worth. And so when
you're looking at a product offering,
especially within education, we have to
think what components of this are
consumed on a regular basis. communities
consumed on a regular basis. If I taught
someone how to do 3D printing and I
said, "Hey, these are the the hot items
that are that are trending right now for
3D printing and I do that research and I
deliver that list every single week."
That's consumable. We have to think
about what are the elements of this and
that's on a uh you know, if we're if
we're if we're teaching someone how to
do anything, right? Um elements of the
business that are consumable and then
there's some elements of the business
that are onetime. the appropriate
billing structure is very high high
price price to value for the onetime
thing that is inherently valuable but
has no recurring and then make sure the
recurring elements of the business are
also appropriately priced which might be
significantly lower and this is what
gave birth to the the little ism that I
have which is big head long tail um and
typically it also leans into
psychological bias of hey I just paid a
lot of money for this thing why would I
cancel this recurring subscription just
to maintain my my skill set here now the
two more elements that you can add in
terms of stickiness can
um uh discount buying which is that if
you have a lot of people who are buying
paint brushes because you taught them
how to paint. If you say hey if you buy
you know I have this collective buying
power and so I will give you you will
get discounts on your materials that are
half or in excess of my subscription
price it's highly likely that people
will be uh people will stick on your
thing because it's very clear ROI for
them. They save more than they spend so
they'll keep doing it. And so the other
component that you can add in from a
stickiness perspective is continued
education. So some of the most valuable
companies in the education space are
actually adult continued education.
Meaning, oh, I'm a nurse. I need to get
these continued credits. I need to keep
up uh with the up-to-date technology.
And think of news as the thing. So
what's the news in the industry? What
are the new techniques? What are the new
tools uh that I can teach on a
consistent basis so this person can stay
up to speed? And again, the amount that
you have to pay to become a doctor
versus the amount that you have to pay
to stay a doctor significantly
different. You might have to pay
$250,000 to become a doctor and $3,000 a
year for your continued credits. All
right? And so, make sure that the
pricing is appropriate to the value
that's being provided. All right? So,
that is the that is the problem um that
you have to solve within that business.
And so, how do we actually win in the
model? One is we split out the value to
make sure that we're charging
appropriately for the one-time thing
versus the recurring thing. We add the
consumable components to the recurring
elements of the business. Uh we want to
use the cash engine that we get from the
one-time purchases to fund uh one
acquisition and most importantly and
this is the biggest one of all brand.
And you might notice this as a recurring
theme here, but how can you defend
against the low barrier entry
uh you creating your competition? How do
you defend against that brand? And in
all of these models, I think the one
that is the most impacted by it's tough
to even say that because they're all
impacted by brand. This one also is
impacted by brand a lot. Um is is is
education, right? Why are people willing
to pay to go and take calculus at
Harvard versus calculus at CCBC and pay
$2,000 versus $200,000? Why are they
willing to pay that difference? Because
of the brand, right? That is why. And so
that brand association also becomes
another value ad to the person because
that brand actually approximates for a
decrease in risk an increase in
likelihood that they will get the
education that they ultimately want.
right now Harvard because it's you know
becomes a stamp in and of itself which
is a little bit different but that is
the ultimate direction you want to go in
is that when your brand is so good that
when people know that they have been
educated by you that that actually
confers value to them for whatever
they're trying to do next so you might
have heard of konl which is a um uh
cooking school right and if someone's
like I'm a cordon blue chef then you're
like oh well there there you go
cordonlue or whatever they say all right
um if you if you uh are one of their
chefs, then you're more likely to get a
job afterwards because they have a good
reputation for for delivering good
chefs. So what does that mean they get
to do? They get to charge more for the
education that they have because their
people are more successful, right? And
so that is how you win in this model.
And if you're in a BTOC setting, so you
sell a consumer skill or education, so
you teach them how to cook, you teach
them how to paint, you teach them how to
skateboard, you teach them how to
whatever, right? In that business model,
the best way to be successful is to be
really good.
If you're really good at skateboarding,
people want to know learn how to do
ollies from you. Even if many people
could do an ollie, they will want to
learn it from you. Because humans have
this very interesting phenomena,
something that I've I've thought a lot,
which is that we have like this overkill
bias. So what does that mean? If I want
to buy a jacket, I want to see that the
jacket is still warm on Mount Everest
because I think, okay, if it's cold, if
it's warm, if it's still warm on the top
of Mount Everest, it'll probably keep me
warm from my car to the door, right? And
to the same degree, they do the same
thing within education. I I want to go
to Tony Hawk, who's a skateboarder for
those of you who are born under a rock.
Um, first 900. Shout out to Tony. Um,
I want Tony Hawk to teach me how to do
an ollie. Now, how many skateboarders
could probably teach you to do an ollie?
A ton. But if you're going to if you had
your brothers, if you had your pick, who
would you pick? The best guy. So, one of
the best branding strategies that you
can have is real world proof, right? Why
does why does the ACQ business content
do I would say disproportionately better
than many other quote business
educators? Well, one I think that I, you
know, tried to do a good job on on the
stuff, but I think the other just
reality of is it like, well, people
didn't pay attention as much to my stuff
until I had a $4,600 exit. And then all
of a sudden, people like, oh, you know,
stuff might be pretty good. And then
people just paid more attention. You
could have the exact same education if
you took everything that Warren Buffett
has taught between every single public
appearance and you turned it into a
course and you said how to invest for
the long term. How many people would
want to buy it? Probably not that many.
You could make it even better than
Warren Buffett. all of his stuff. The
only thing you forgot to do was build
Berkshire Hathaway that did $89
billion in profit last year. That's what
you forgot to do starting at age seven
and doing it for like a hundred years
almost literally. All right. And so he
has the world real world proof. And so
if you want to win in education, the
best way to start is be better than
everyone.
And if you're like, well, how easy for
you to say? Yes, easy for me to say,
hard for me to get here, right? And I'm
not saying I'm better than everyone. I'm
just saying that as there are levels to
the game and you will be you will be
truncated you will be capped by how good
you are because that will have a direct
correlation to the amount of brand
association that you will be able to get
the amount of credibility that you have.
So if you want to get if you want to
have a bigger brand and you want to get
into education, my my two cents is even
though it is easy, fast uh uh and and
cheap to start,
the real way to win is to take the much
longer time path of proving that you're
very good or one of the best at the
thing. And then when you do decide to
start educating people, they will listen
to you immediately and they will not
question why you're more expensive. They
will not question uh whether or not you
can do it. you will pay down all of the
biggest risks within this business. And
you pay it down doing the one thing that
the rest of your competition won't do,
which is be patient and do the work.
Which brings us naturally to number
four.
I wanted to make a crude comment about
SAS and ass. Well, there you go. SAS and
ass. Um uh so what is the shape of this
business and why is it this shape? So
software starts the slowest because you
have to put a lot of capital in. You
have to put people together and you have
to have people code for extended periods
of time. Not really sure if people
actually even like the thing and if they
do like the thing. How long does it take
for it to actually do all the functions
that you have in your mind uh for it and
so this takes you know for in the
beginning you know not that long ago it
took many years. Um and it still takes
time now even with the vibe coding
world. I still real talk have yet to see
a truly vibecoded from a toz business uh
that is like a hundred million dollars a
year and I even you know we had a
conversation with Amjod who's replet CEO
one of the the key uh I think they're at
150 million or something like ARR u in a
very short time period we had a
conversation um about uh people who use
Replet to vibe code software and
interestingly I think he mentioned one
or two examples and they have like lots
lots and lots and lots and lots of
customers of like $1 million businesses,
$2 million businesses that use the vibe
coded software. And so I think that it
is getting better and better. Um, is it
there yet? I think it has struggled to
have the robustness of I'll just call it
manual or humanbased software, but I
think that will get fixed in time and
probably relatively quickly. But for
right now, it still does take time and
takes years uh to make a truly good
product that is also scalable. So sure,
maybe you can sell it to a handful of
people, but can it support a million
users? Not currently. The vibe coding
wrong. But it's shaped this way because
taking out vibe coding for a moment.
Once you do have product market fit, the
way that Y Combinator describes this is
that getting product market fit is like
pushing a boulder up the hill. And once
you have it, it's like chasing uh
getting chased by the boulder on the
other way down, right? Is that you're
chasing after this because you have so
much more demand um than you can even
handle. and like the wheels come flying
off. So it's shaped this way because
it's hard to build a good product.
Engineering is especially good engineers
incredibly expensive. You have to front
that capital because you have no income,
right? Think about this. The rest of
these businesses, you can get pretty
close to bootstrapping SAS. The reason
there is such a big venture capital
industry is because it costs money,
millions of dollars to get the level of
talent required to make great products
um in engineering. And you have to front
that for like a year, sometimes two
years before you even turn a dollar,
right? And definitely not enough dollars
to make it profitable. And so you have
this very long, very unprofitable
runway. And so as a result of all the
businesses I just described, the fewest
number of businesses are here are in
software and it's because the barriers
to entry are higher. Now vibe coding,
things like that have made it easier.
More people are coding now. Some
engineers can there's coding boot camps
plus vibe coding where people can do
components of their job with it. And so
it's becoming more democratized. That
being said, it's still between the other
three way fewer people here compared to
the other ones.
But it is shaped this way because once
you have product more fit, you can go to
the sky because it is the most scalable
of all four business models. Once you
have it, again, that's the hard part. So
what's the great part about it? U
infinite scale, incredibly high gross
margins. Uh once you have it, if done
well, if done well, very sticky revenue.
The vast majority of people who build
software don't have sticky revenue, but
if done well, can be incredibly sticky
because it gets integrated into
someone's workflow. Um and you can have
huge enterprise value long term. So why
do software companies have such high
valuations? Um one person can exit it
because somebody else can own the
product and the customer can have the
exact same experience. So there's almost
no risk at point of sale if all the
other metrics of the business are there.
Number one. Number two, the components
that drive valuation are outside of that
core component of software is going to
be gross margin and growth rate. So how
much gross margin do we have and how
quickly are we growing? Now the third
element of this growth rate which almost
always happens at scale gets factored in
is going to be revenue retention. So of
course you can go from 0 to$10 million
very quickly because you can just sell a
lot of people something and you'll have
high growth rate, high gross margins.
But if the customers are leaving, we
have no stickiness. We have no we and
this is where many people who come from
this world in the information education
world or services world uh or even
e-commerce world, they say, "Oh, this
shouldn't be hard. I can have an
infinite backend. I'll just cobble some
stuff together. I'll get an outsourced
developer and we'll we'll go sell the
thing." The problem is this business
looks identical to this business, the
information business, until you have
revenue retention.
Real
So
that becomes the priority in this
business. And
I'm getting ahead of myself. So I'll
tell you how to do that in a second. So
let me tell you what sucks about this
because I just told you, oh the infinite
scale, lots of money, huge enterprise
value, lots of gross margins. Why does
it suck? Very slow start. Founders often
quit early, very high burn in terms of
cash before you start having money. And
even when you do make money, you're
still burning more than you're making
because because of how software works
because of its infinite scale, the vast
majority of people are not willing to
pay a lot of money for it. So if you
think about how much uh even enterprise
software costs, it might cost a few
hundred,000 a year, but compared to the
expenses that an enterprise actually
spends on other costs, it's nothing,
right? It feels high to the software
company, but it's nothing compared to
how much the enterprise actually spends.
And on a consumer level, you know, the
amount that you have to do to get $9 a
month from a person speaking from
experience is a lot, [laughter] right?
Think about think about Netflix, which
is a combination of media and kind of
software. They have to make the entire
they have to entertain the world and
make worldclass, you know, shows. They
have to make The Witcher. They have to
make they have to make these
unbelievable shows just so they can get
their $10 a month. and they go to 13 and
people like, I'm leaving, right?
Outrageous. $13. Where are these what
are these people talking about? Right?
And so people's willingness to pay
because they know there's almost no
incremental cost is very low, which
means you have to have tremendous volume
to actually make real money. Now, the
advantage is it can handle that volume,
but it sure as hell is hard to get 100
million customers, right? And so it can
become very emotionally difficult uh for
this long period of time where it
basically never makes money. And so then
you have dependency on VCs or you have
to just watch your bank account go down
month after month after month uh in
order to maintain as much equity as you
can so you don't dilute yourself to the
point where finally it does succeed and
you own 4% of the business and that
there's more you know scar stories
behind that than than I can possibly
tell you. So what's the problem that you
have to solve? Number one is you have to
survive their early years before product
market fit. This is the biggest issue.
Um, and this is where marketers
basically just can't do software. It's
just like it's it's incredibly hard for
them to do because they want to market.
They want to sell it. But in order for
this thing to actually become big, you
have to make sure that people want it
and keep wanting it. They have to stick.
And so, not only do they have to buy,
they have to keep using it. And so, that
is the hardest part of doing it. I was
listening to an interview by the Dropbox
uh founder and he was talking about how
he used to pay people from Craigslist to
come in and just use his product in
front of him and he said the first time
they did it, five out of five people who
used it didn't upload a file because
they couldn't figure it out. And so that
is the kind of just raw work you have to
keep doing and it's like maybe it takes
them another three weeks or four weeks
to get the next user flow uh going and
then they have to get more people in
front of them and then those people
still don't figure it out and you keep
doing that until eventually like oh my
god they uploaded a file and then from
there we're like okay well now they
didn't come back So then we have
to fix that loop and so there's many
loops that have to get completely
lubricated within the user experience of
the business so they can actually
deliver core value and you have to do
that as fast as humanly possible. And so
within the software world, there's a
great interview or a presentation that
uh the head of growth uh at Facebook
said and he drew this line
and he said people think growth looks
like this. He said growth actually looks
like this.
So what does he mean by that?
He means that users start, they get
activated and then they never turn. That
is what growth looks like. Because if
you can retain a certain percentage of
customers forever, then it means all you
do is you can just keep filling in the
front end, but then that base level just
keeps sticking and growing and growing
and growing. And that is how software
companies become incredibly valuable. So
the biggest problem you have to solve is
number one making a product that people
want to buy and number two making sure
that they keep buying it, they keep
coming back, they keep spending money on
it. That's the issue. And so on a
consumer side, if you're keeping over
60% um by the end of the year from logos
perspective, ideally over 100% from a
revenue perspective, that becomes an
incredibly valuable business. And so
what do I mean the difference between
I'm going to get a little bit softery,
but logo turn versus revenue. Um so
revenue retention is if I have 10
customers that pay me $10 a month, that
means that I'm making $100 a month. A
year later, am I still making $100 a
month from those initial customers? Now,
I might have lost a few of those
customers, but if some of those other
customers spend more money because we
build our software in such a way that we
have the opportunity for them to spend
more. If we have more than $100 from
those original customers, we have 100%
or greater revenue retention. That's the
game you want to be in. And that works
the same for consumers as it does for uh
software, sorry, for uh for enterprise
sales, for B2B. So, all the way through.
Now, it tends to be easier to have stick
on enterprise customers because they're
willing to incur more costs. uh
switching costs are higher for them
whereas consumers it's harder but
there's a whole hell of a lot of them so
how do you win in software or in SAS
number one you have to obsess over
product quality and customer feedback
you have to be absolutely customer
obsessed
so at school for example so we own a
software platform um we have 20 million
users right so kind of you know kind of
legit um pretty you know people think
it's people think it's a big deal um So
in order to do that you have to be
absolutely militant. And one of the
interesting things about this is that
it's not that you listen to the
customers that you give customers
everything they want because the c
customers will uh hang themselves with
their own requests, right? And so if you
just keep feature adding, feature adding
feature adding uh you end up building a
Frankenstein that no one can make their
way through, right? Right? And so you
have to be incredibly diligent in terms
of what features we really think are
going to be worth the the cost of the
user experience that we're adding in
complexity. And so complexity is the
antithesis of this of of elegance,
right? And so when you add more stuff,
it almost always adds complexity unless
you have exceptional product design. And
that you can only do with just tons of
loops of iteration of thinking time and
intelligence um and feedback to make it.
It's kind of like sanding off the edges.
Um, and it's the tiny little details
that make software work. So, two
companies can have the same core problem
that they're solving, but the level of
quality that they can approach it with
is so much greater um with that. So,
next one is uh in terms of the the way
you win in this. So, you have to retain
the customers. Uh, the next one is you
have to have some sort of viral
component to the business. We want to
have a loop um to this so that when we
bring one customer they bring 1.1 right
they get an extra customer in the door
for us because at the ultimate scale
especially with software that tends to
be lower priced um it becomes very
difficult to use paid ads as your
primary way of acquiring customers uh
and so you you can absolutely use paid
ads uh as a way to get customers but you
need to have some viral loop that over
time can continually compound down the
cost of acquisition and so like Facebook
would have had to spend gazillions of
dollars. They spent for sure a lot of
money to acquire customers. But the key
component that they knew is that if they
could spend to acquire one, they could
get two more or whatever their viral
coefficient was um to come afterwards.
So that takes that cost and then divides
it by three because two other customers,
but then those customers get two other
customers and it continues to
proliferate, right? Chat GBT was able to
get to a million users in a week because
of virality, because of strong word of
mouth.
The other way um that I would I would
note is that software is a quality over
quantity game when it comes to talent.
There absolutely are 10x and 100x extra
to engineers. They also tend to cost 10
or 100x the price. And so you have to be
willing to spend a huge amount of money
for way better talent. The difficulty is
if you've never built software before to
have the perspective from which to make
the judgment on that talent.
And so this is where you becoming
educated or you being very good in and
of yourself or getting your a strong
technical co-founder uh can be important
for having a good filter for who really
has the chops to code and always
building with the end in mind of like we
need to build this thing with scalable
code, good documentation from day one.
Um so that this thing can really rip
once we have product market fit and our
viral coefficient um figured out. And
then the loops where we get return
loops, we get uh referral loops, we have
you know upgrade loops, all the
different loops that have get built into
the user experience. We've removed all
the friction from them. And I'll leave
you with one final thing from design
which is
the way you make an exceptional product
is that you cannot actually make
something good. What you do is you find
a good outcome that everybody wants.
That's the easy part. And that you
remove all friction between where
someone is and them getting that
outcome. That is what good software
does. And so if you think about all the
benefits that come with having a phone
and you remove all the friction
associated with that, you get an iPhone.
That's what Steve Jobs did so
brilliantly. He looked at what everyone
wants with a phone and said, "How can I
make it so it's so easy that a child,
literally babies, people who don't speak
English, can figure out how to use the
device and get what they want out of it
and they can do it immediately.
That is how good software is built. It's
by the removal of friction. If you
remove everything that sucks about
getting what someone wants, by default,
you will have something good. So, the
reason I wanted to go over these in so
much depth is that every business has
features and bugs like I I said earlier.
And one of the big mistakes that I'll
see businesses do at different levels,
and I'm talking not just like, you know,
a million or 10 million, but I see $30
million, $50 million, $100 million
businesses um come and come with similar
issues, which is their complaint will be
a core feature of the business and they
will say there's something wrong with my
business because I'm struggling with
supply chain issues. I'm struggling with
cash flow as we're scaling too quickly
or I'm really supply constrained because
it's really hard to find good people or
you know what, you know, getting
customers is tough. like ad spend is is
going up and it's costing me more to get
customers every single year and ads
don't really work like they used to or
you know it's really expensive to do
this company and we're burning a ton of
money and we're just hoping we can make
it to our next round but we're not
keeping customers as long as we really
need to. We're not hitting our revenue
retention goals. Every one of these
business has features. All right, these
are the core hairy problems that make
these businesses these businesses. And
so as soon as you can identify one
there's nothing wrong with your
business. This is the core struggle that
creates the model that you chose to get
into. And so if you know that the flip
side is that the what's hard for you is
hard for somebody else, which means that
if you conquer that problem, you unlock
huge amounts of enterprise value. And so
the way that I think about this when I'm
approaching these problems is how much
enterprise value will I unlock if all of
a sudden my service business I can get
two people up to speed per month? Well,
if I got two people up to speed per
month, I might add $10 million
enterprise value or $50 million in
enterprise value to my business. Okay.
Well, if that were the case, am I
willing to dedicate
$100,000 of resources, $500,000 of
resources and time to solve that $50
million problem? Hell yeah, I am. And so
once once you can appropriately
appreciate the value of the hairy
problem that you're trying to solve, you
can then put the right resources towards
solving it rather than constantly
questioning yourself and thinking, "Oh,
there must be something wrong with my
business." And I think just having that
level of clarity of there's nothing
wrong. This is the problem that I get to
solve. This is what the marketplace will
literally pay me gobs of money to just
figure out. And so by then saying,
"Okay, this is my focal point." and just
shutting the rest out. You can then get
really clear on, okay, if I have to
solve this problem and I have to
thoroughly solve it, not halfass, not
duct tape. This is core to the value
creation of my business,
that's where you win because then you
can put all that depth of effort into it
and get exceptionally good at
recruiting, training, um, and building
amazing people. You can get
exceptionally good at cash flow
management, supply chain management, and
and logistics and building the brand
around it. You can get exceptionally
good at building the brand and getting
very clear on how to separate out what
you charge for in terms of one-time and
continuity and building in those
components of stickiness so that someone
who gets educated still wants to stay
with you. Or building the most
worldclass cracked engineering team on
the planet so that you can shorten the
amount of time that it takes you to find
the product market fit and you build a
scaleup infrastructure so that people
actually love the product, they retain
revenue and then this thing compounds
and takes off like a rocket. That's the
core hairy problem that you have to
solve. That's the 10x or 100x value that
you as the entrepreneur, this is what we
get paid for. This is the game. And so
if you haven't started a business and
you're like, "Wow, all of these sound
great and all of them sound hard." Well,
which one is right for you? It depends a
little bit. And I almost wanted to make
a quiz on this for like what's your
personality type? Can you match the
business to the personality type? I
think you kind of can. Um because some
personalities are just like more willing
to suffer for longer periods of time.
they're more, you know, uh, detail
oriented and they're they're very
particular. It's like, well, if I said,
hey, I have an engineering person who
has some mix of creativity, disregards,
uh, the opinions of other and is willing
to suffer for long periods of time. Who
is that software founder? Right? If I
said I've got somebody who's like really
excited, super promotional, doesn't like
details, um, but just like loves
promoting, what's a good business for
that person? One of these, right? Good
promoters do really well in e-commerce.
Good promoters do really well in
education. Now again, you still have to
have a good product like all businesses,
but these tend to be more marketing
heavy. If I have somebody who's just
exceptionally skilled at something and
is a very good teacher, ironically, some
of the best teachers at stuff can have
amazing service businesses. And if
you're somebody who loves people, this
is a business that you want to be in,
right? Because you're going to always
have people around you. If you love
building culture, if you love which I
actually didn't talk about um but
culture is going to be the internal
brand of this business and because you
have to get many people to behave in a
specific way. Brand is how you do that
to customers. Culture is how you do that
to your employees. And so if you can
develop people and you love pouring into
people and you like leading people,
notice people being the main word for
all of this. The three other business
models have far fewer people. There's
people for sure, but far fewer than a
service business. service businesses,
you got to love people in order to do
them. And so that should give you a
little bit of a mix of which one might
be right for you and what path you might
be on. Here's the best part of all. I've
owned all of them and I've done well in
all of them. So, it's not to say that
one is better than the other. It's just
that which one's right for you and which
one's right for you right now. And the
best part is life is long. You can
change your mind later because you can
get out of that business because the
reality is that if you've never started
a business before, the likelihood the
first business you start is the last
business you own is almost zero. Bonus
section. So what shape is
acquisition.com if you're curious?
So acquisition.com it depends on the
revenue line actually. So the books uh
the books if we want to include that and
ACQAI um is kind of a blend of these
right here because ACQAI is software um
but the books and the bundle was an
education related product if you want to
call it that. And so, uh, because I have
marketed a lot and I have a lot of
people that have made money using my
stuff, um, they've had good experiences
with my free stuff. And so, they were
like, well, if he has, uh, you know, the
AI and I'm willing to donate books, uh,
to help Alex's mission, which is my my
whole thing. Um, which is getting more
books in the hands of entrepreneurs
because books are what changed my life.
Um, then that was a combination of these
two, which is why it was able to do a
significant amount of revenue in like a
weekend, right? Like how else could you
scale a business? Like there's uh you
know people like we they went from zero
to 100 million in ARR in X period of
time. It's like well I went from zero to
100 million in 60 hours, right? uh if
you get if you can promote well enough
and and you have a good a good offer and
a good product and you have a good
history uh with an audience then the
likelihood that they'll want to buy the
next thing and this is where I think
people go wrong is that the best
marketers in the world find the best
products because they know like I feel
confident that I can sell a lot of stuff
but because I don't care about the first
sale I want to care about the 10th sale
I want to make sure the thing that I
deliver is exceptional so that my second
sale is bigger than my first one right
if my first book sucked no one would
have come to my like my my first book
launch with leads. If the leads booket
suck, no one would want to have come to
the money models launch, right? If the
products and the playbooks and money
models book sucks, no one's going to
come to the next one. But I feel pretty
good based on how everything's going
that people like that book, too. All
right? Because I put so much time into
it and it's what I know and what I'm
good at. Um, and so that's the that is
the the media component of the business.
If you consider um uh media also kind of
tends to fall in this a little bit of a
blend between these two um of like you
have a scalable deliverable um
and so it's combo of these two. Now uh
in terms of the advisory practice pure
pure service the advisory practice is a
pure service business. It's white collar
service. We have associates uh who
basically we have analysts that come in
and they have career paths that then
leads them to be associates and there's
career paths within associates. So
junior uh associate and then senior
associate um and then from there they
can become uh directors and so we have
clear career paths for people and it
takes years for people to go through
that uh to learn kind of an apprentice
style model which is very akin to many
professional service types businesses.
accounting, management, consulting,
which is basically what we are. Um, uh,
legal, many types of businesses have
same similar style models, which is very
high, uh, education, uh, people. We have
lots of Ivy League guys, uh, who work on
the team, many people who have had
exrepreneur experience or combinations
of both of those. Um, and so that is
that's the game and that's the those are
the two uh, kind of models that we have.
So we have HQAI, which is technically
this. We had the um the media uh and
books which is technically here. We have
the service um that's here. Uh I mean
Leila did a you know she think she did a
t-shirt drop or an apparel drop but
that's technically e-commerce. Um and so
yeah I've I've owned all those but the
contribution margin you know
contribution for I won't even mention
what you know the contribution for for
for the e-commerce stuff is is minimal
uh compared to the other components of
the business. But uh if you are curious
that's what we do. And then um I'd say
the the larger question is what what
kind of what kind of business is an
investment firm, right? What kind of
business is that? Um I think that that
type of business
is
it's kind of a vehicle that contains
businesses more than it's a business in
and of itself. Like an investment
business doesn't actually make money
unless the businesses that are contained
within it make money. And so typically
because capital creates so much
leverage, you can have very few people
making a handful of very important
decisions with large amounts of money
that can then create value in excess of
the money that went in. Right? Um you
know a.com from the portfolio
perspective, we have an insurance
company. So, an insurance company, I
would say, is more akin to this uh
service business because you have
account reps, they have to maintain
accounts. Um, and it's it tends to be a
high headcount business because you have
to get more and more agents in. Um, we
own brickandmortar service which also
falls in this category. We have teeth
whitening chain um with weiden.
Uh, and so that chain um we have a B2B
um kind of uh operational consulting
business um that I would say is a bit of
a blend between these two. I would say
it's like tech enabled uh or media
enabled, education enabled if you will,
but we have really good revenue
retention. So, it's a it has a little
bit more it skews more towards service
um on that side. And so, we have
different businesses inside of the
portfolio um that you know continue to
grow. And yeah, so that's that's what we
do.
And hopefully if you're a business
owner, uh that helps you at least know a
little bit more about the path that
you're on. And if you are about to start
on the business journey, first off, good
luck. It'll take longer than you think
and it'll probably suck for way longer
than you think it will. Um, and once you
get in, you never get out.